if you don't remember what Byron Scott
was as a player you missed out on one of
the great shooters I think in NBA
history I think you averaged twenty to
one year does that sound about right
sounds about right
okay but you were more that 18-foot
jumper would you have been a more of a
22 23 24 foot jumper if you played today
with today's style absolutely our team
wasn't built that way like you said back
in those days that's just not how you
play basketball you were really a more
of an inside-out you know team and
that's what we have with James Worthy
you know Kareem abdul-jabbar magic was
able to going to post so we didn't rely
on three-pointers you know that was
almost the last result you know when
teams were double teaming us but you
know myself and Michael Cooper magic to
a certain extent you know got his game
so developed that he was able to shoot
threes as well but we just didn't do
that on a regular basis but now in
today's game you know I if I shot five
threes in one game Dan that was that was
like unbelievable you know so I probably
would do that now in in in in 1/2 you
know if I heard opportunity bird didn't
shoot threes nobody really shot him deck
back then you know not not to this type
of you know productivity where guys are
shooting them you know 20 30 times a
game night guys but teenies in general
that just wasn't something that we did
on a regular basis you know like I said
we wanted to feature our best players
Kareem and James and Magic and those
guys were great on the block if you
didn't double-team them they were gonna
score if you did double-team and now you
leaving myself Michael Cooper and guys
like that open there's so many angles I
want to touch on here let me start with
greatest Laker of all time if this was
the topic on Monday I know you played
with magic and Kareem yeah yeah but
could you step in you coach Kobe yeah
could you say who the greatest Laker of
all time is that's the tough one you
know I I go back and forth with that
because people asked me that question
and when you talk about those three guys
I don't think you get any argument from
a lot of people I think they'll all get
votes as obviously but man magic and cat
you know cat leading scorer in the
history of this game
to me is considered probably the
greatest player in the game and then you
got magic who's the greatest teammate
greatest late leader I've ever been
around
so I look at those two guys and I'm
probably a little bit biased because I
played with those guys for a number of
years but I love Kobe as well you know I
came in I went out when he was coming in
you know got to know him extremely well
got to be extremely close so I can't
pick between those three down to be
honest but if you were starting a team I
gave you magic Kareem Kobe mmm what era
at age 20 200 starting a team in a
sophist I'm taking Kareem Kareem okay
but how about today today's game it will
probably be between magic and Kobe could
you imagine magic if you can't put your
hand because could he have averaged 30 a
game if he wanted yes yes but that
wasn't that wasn't magic nature you know
he was so much of a team player and
getting his his teammates involved that
he never really thought about scoring
that was the third or fourth thing he
thought about I mean the one you Riley
had to challenge him and say we need you
to be more aggressive offensively I mean
when he was more aggressive we were a
better basketball team well he won the
title with that one-man show against the
six right right what 42 42 and 15 is
something like that and seven assist and
started this Center yeah you know I mean
played all five positions that that that
game yeah so he's one of those unique
players that you can put him on the
floor
and he's gonna flourish and he's gonna
make his teammates better but where are
all the big men now I don't know words
here Byron all these guys over 6 11 7
feet guys that were be sinners back in
our day porzingis is on the perimeter 73
yes and he's the guy this you know you
know he's above the three-point line I
mean he can be above the 3-point line so
the game is just obviously changed you
know big-time Dan from where it used to
be to where it is now and it's still an
exciting game but you just got these
guys who are so much more athletic at
seven one seven two seven three they can
put the ball on the floor and also can
spread the floor and make shots from
three
if we redid the draft who would the
Lakers have taken it number two last
year yeah I still think we were took
D'Angela instead of porzingis probably
so oh you're saying that with a smile on
your face not the coach anymore
I'll tell you what porzingis you take
Portia make that kid I think he has you
know upside just just unbelievable but
he's you need he's very unique i-73
yes again we had him in and worked out
and he wasn't in great shape at that
particular time and you just didn't see
all this you know you knew the kid would
be good but you thought he would be good
in three or four years you thing because
this year this early in the summer he
wasn't in shape right right and that was
there any discussion about taking him at
- yes well let me behind the curtain
here what was the discussion here it was
it was it close it was pretty close it
was pretty close
and again when you can only have a guy
in for an individual workout that's
that's real tough you know because a lot
of guys look great individual workouts
and there's a lot of guys that don't you
know I always really felt that if you
can have a guy in or our group of guys
where they can play a three-on-three
basketball then you really get a better
idea if these guys can play right away
you know like I said he just came in
town he was pretty worn out after like
20 minutes so you just didn't get a
chance to see everything that he's
capable of doing and tell the seasons
starting we saw him in the summer league
I said wow this kid's gonna be pretty
good you know so I mean there was
serious discussion about him and
probably if you'd have been in great
shape then there would have been even
more serious discussions about him no
doubt about Karl Anthony towns though no
doubt about it I mean he's he's he's
real so I'm work out and we said right
away dang we wish we had the first pick
I mean because he you knew right away
watching him work out that this kid was
gonna be special we're talking to Byron
Scott the Byron Scott basketball camp by
the way Fullerton College runs through
August 1st August 1st through the 5th
and also a new book out in June of next
year called for the win now is this
gonna
are you gonna be addition is there
gossip in here for the wind what are we
talking about here now you know what it
is it's a collaboration between me and a
friend of mine named Charlie North's my
workout buddy for seven years and
Charlie Norris about three weeks ago
just at the beautiful age of 70
so this this this guy and I are in the
gym and people always look at us and say
what do you guys have in common
you know he's five six five seven you
know real short guy and little bald you
know and and we just we just clicked and
we decided one day we were sitting on
the mat stretch of sand man we should
just do an exercise book well the
exercise book is turned into something
obviously totally different and really
what the book is really talking about is
that the the similarities of coaching a
basketball team are running the
franchise as they in running a business
because that's what he does for a living
so it's a lot of stories in there a lot
of similarities on some of the things
he's done in his life that pertains to
running a business and how basketball
and business kind of you know corn talk
entwined each other and we just think
it's a unique story and we just decided
to you know get a little bit more
serious about it and hired a writer and
he thought it was great and here we go
so the book coming out next tune is
called for the wind talking to Byron
Scott
we had Rex Chapman and yesterday and Rex
of course former NBA player was in the
front office for an NBA team and he
talked about Ben Simmons and he talked
about the lack of maturity mm-hmm how
concerned would you be when you hear
something like that questionable
teammate how concerned would you be as a
coach or your team in position as the
Lakers might be to take Ben Simmons I
think you draw some red flags obviously
I think as the general manager or the
owner of a team you don't have to dig it
a little bit deeper and find out a
little bit more about the history of the
kid the maturity part doesn't doesn't
really affect me as much as what I saw
on the basketball court because what I
saw is a guy with great skills really
handled a ball great passer seems like
you have very good IQ for a basketball
player at his age
but I didn't see a whole lot of passion
from him
times and to be the best player in
college basketball and not be able to
get LSU that team to an NC double-a you
know tournament that's the thing that
worries me more than anything but you
think he wanted to be there at all Byron
I think he went there for one reason
that he was gonna play one year probably
didn't go to class
yeah and I'm out of here you know so I
think he knew at 18 years old I'm gonna
play one year college basketball and it
just depends on where I want to play and
then I'm going to the pros so I don't
think he had a whole lot of intentions
on being there you know much longer than
one year and I think his goal was just
to get me in Bay that's the bottom line
but can I blame him or do I blame the
system because he he has to go through
the motions here because he knows that
his next time to the NBA he doesn't want
to get injured right you know I had a
problem that it just didn't feel like he
loved being there like he was passionate
the best player in the game should be
having a whole lot of fun absolutely
absolutely and I think a lot of it is
the system you know I've been one of
those guys that's been talking about a
you basketball for a long time how I
think it's destroying a lot of these
young guys anyway you know so I think
he's you know he's one of those guys is
put in that a little bit of a you know
that box and this is what you're gonna
do and you know been privileged and
handed it you know did the silver spoon
and all that stuff all his life and so
you know he felt that hey I'm gonna go
here one year really just for basketball
just to get to the next level but you
were in this position and and we brought
this up the last time I talked to you I
mean you're coaching kids who are the
age of your kids and they got this money
they're on center stage they're they're
hanging with the kardashians I mean
they're doing they're doing it's crazy
and you're trying to coach to keep your
job and you're trusting these 20 year
olds did not be knuckleheads out there
it's tough like you said first of all
then all my kids older than these guys
25 so yeah it I mean it makes you
scratch your head because you have these
kids and you're trying to introduce them
to you know I always say the N V stands
for no boys allowed you know I mean
you're trying to introduce them to a
man's game you know on an everyday basis
and when they leave that gym a lot of
these kids
they have so much auto idle time and
they have so much money and they're used
to going to school for a little while
and things like that but you practice at
11 o'clock let's just go back to last
year so most of these kid reports at 10
o'clock by 2 o'clock 3 o'clock they're
done so for the rest of the day what are
you gonna do how you gonna spend your
time so that's where a lot of these kids
get in trouble is because they just have
too much idle time and too much money to
spend so it's a hard job because you got
to think about them outside the
basketball court as well as on the court
will continue with Byron Scott few other
things I'm sure you got a Michael Jordan
story and I'm sure you got a Larry Bird
story to tell us I got a couple of them
yeah I got I got one of each of those ok
I did want to ask you though I mean I
was looking at the staff over you guys
look really good today and night when I
normally watch the store you guys look
ok and then you look better so what's
what's the deal today you look like they
normally look and they look like you
normally look what's the deal uh I'm
just curious I mean I'm just I they
wanted to make over oh these guys wanted
to wear makeup they're in Hollywood Oh
Kevin Frazier from Entertainment Tonight
said i'ma hook you up so he came in and
paulie's got a jacket on that looks
great it costs more than my car
this is Showtime over here if you were
good if you were running with these guys
in the mid 80s with Showtime how do you
think you'd do I'll probably have five
championships dinners then off the court
I'll probably continue with Byron Scott
right after this the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience